[Music]
ladies and gentlemen we have a new
addition
h portico security specializing cash
trucks across la do you have any idea
how dangerous this job can be
somehow yeah we ain't the predators
we're the prey
you ready ready
this is your temporary sidearm why
aren't you fully putting pistols in the
machine guys
do you have a problem i don't know do i
it's a 10 grand drop you should have
been back five minutes ago
they're serious leave this to me
get in the truck next time sorry pal
it doesn't feel right
[Music]
it's like he wants trucks to get hit
he's not a cop but if he's not a cop
what is he
a while back we lost two cars civilian
too
there was an investigation we still
haven't found a scum who did it
you're in an accident you're not my son
he didn't make it i need to not kill my
son
the tree has been shook and it's been
shook hard
we've scorched the earth
you started by certainly do anything
what i'm hearing
is you think you've done everything
[Music]
i can see it's gonna be a long night
it's gotta be an inside job can do it in
two weeks
you know what i wish you could do in 20
years
when i do bury grudge
he has had a tremendous year michael
bryce is the bodyguard of the year
is he a relative of yours god no darius
kincaid's a
hitman wanted for like a zillion murders
around the world and how often do you
have this dream
just once well that's not tonight right
i'm thinking you need to forget
bodyguarding
[Music]
i'm officially on sabbatical and to be
honest i don't know why i didn't do this
sooner
this is the world's been waiting for me
to make this change
for the first time i'm starting to
imagine a life without bodyguarding
this really feels like a new
no bodyguard
that means no guns no killing and no
blood
what is he doing here
are you using pepper spray i'm on
sabbatical
what
i would make a great mother don't you
think oh my god a child would be so
lucky to have you as its host
[Music]
you're gonna tell us everything you know
i'm not telling you yeah
i on the other hand will tell you
everything
the world has the way of changing
[Music]
[Music]
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not going to think
about the submarine
[Music]
and now we got cars flying in the air
[Music]
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
been a long time dog little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
he's got his own private army we need
help
[Music]
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
[Music]
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
[Music]
crank it all the way up get back with
the soldiers
man we messing with magnets now if you
woke up
whoa
we supposed to stop that hold on
and now
you spend the rest of yours
not today
really duct tape you acting like we on
our way to home depot
i don't wanna die
[Music]
why'd they put you in a fire tower
[Music]
well i'm just lucky i guess
i read the wind wrong
[Music]
i should have gone to them
[Music]
then you've been dead too
that's our job
[Music]
hey stop i'm not going to hurt you i
want to see where the blood's coming
from it's not my blood
you in trouble
anyone else in trouble
my dad said if anything happened i
should find someone i could trust
are you someone i can trust
we promise absolutes
act accordingly
did you see their faces
[Music]
cut you down
give them something else to worry about
that eats everything in its path
you really want to die for this kid
take it deep bruh
hold it
and lay back
what happens next
you're looking right in the eyes
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
his exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you may very well
mean the difference between life
and death
your reputation precedes you have to
admit i wasn't expecting an invitation
back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting
two versus one he's got to be kids
smoke in the air
[Music]
on your feet senior chief
john kelly is more dangerous and
effective
than any man we have in the field
[Music]
the only thing he has more than kills
are medals
somebody would like to talk to you john
if you're done in there
we need you to get back in the field
senior chief kelly it appears you have a
common enemy with the united states
they took everything from me
my family i got nothing left
their plan is a series of strategic
attacks all over the world
we have to respond i need to be on that
team lieutenant commander greer
you lead the mission i'm leaving out the
playing field cia doesn't support any
further investigation into your wife's
murder
battlefield he had no right to take so
much from me
this is a gold mission
what's the real mission
now
[Music]
[Applause]
be kidding me you're gonna risk the
entire mission for a mental defective
dress as a court justice it's coming
from a guy that wears a toilet seat on
his head we don't leave one of our own
behind hopefully harley's still alive
no funny business these are dangerous
people
team two is clear to go fire uh three
two what are you guys doing what
you we're here to save you you were
gonna save me this is a really good plan
too well i can go back inside and you
can still do it that's patronizing i'm
so sorry harley quinn
bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all going to die i hope so
oh for [ __ ] sake here's the deal
we fail the mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no if you cough without
covering your mouth early
although that isn't an open invitation
for you to cough without covering your
mouth
what's the plan how much listen up
you're the leader you're supposed to be
decisive and i've decided that you
should eat a big bag of dicks
but this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem why
would someone put
penises all over the beans well that's
why mad men do what they
well do kind of our thing
[Music]
are you worried i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
[Applause]
oh my god we've got a freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love the rain like angels are
splooting all
over us
you don't know everything about me
i've lived a lot of lives
[Music]
before i was an avenger
before i got this family
i made mistakes choosing between what
the world wants you to be
i know you are
we have to go back to where it all
started
where did you think i was all this time
we have unfinished business
my girls are the toughest girls in the
world i'm sorry
we had our orders and we played our role
it wasn't real
it was real to me
to me you were everything
rainer oh
put your seatbelts on
one thing's for sure
[Music]
i'm done running for my past
[Music]
good morning goldie my name is guy and i
live
in free city i have everything i need
[Music]
except one thing hey
excuse me hey
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what
the stuff we do day after day literally
not once
today's going to be different goldie
what are we looking at
who are you we ran into each other the
other day how did you find me i waited
outside by the murder train guy
i have to tell you something there is no
easy way to say this this world
it's a video game i really want to kiss
you is that weird
listen to me you're not real
wait you let who kiss you guy there's
not a button for that
oh he found the button
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters i am
sitting here with my best friend trying
to help him get through a tough time
now if that's not real i don't know what
it is
millie i know this world is just a game
but this place these people that's all i
have
thanks guys who is this guy this
character in the video game free city
has been turning heads
by being the good guy who is blue shirt
guy you're absolutely right who is he
or she indeed this loser is ruining the
game man
i don't care if he's arnold freaking
schwartz invader terminate him
we're doing great guy in two days the
game is gonna shut down
you this whole city they'll be gone what
if we can save it
was that cool it felt really cool we
could change
our world but we have to fight together
i don't even know what's happening right
now
but i love it this is the first time
i've ever driven a car before
[Music]
they seem nice
[Music]
my flock this will not be
a war of heroes
nations will slaughter each other
this is going to be fun
[Applause]
you cannot keep me locked away as the
world burns
son the truth is the world is ruled
by corruption and greed we must do
something
certainly
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
refined but brutal civilized
but merciless
welcome to the club very clever it's
time
to pour fuel
on the fire of revolution
yes my shepherd
welcome englishman
rasputin your reputation precedes you
[Music]
man
[Music]
why is it that boys are always so messy
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil
to capture a wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
[Music]
it had the same marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen throughout history
different cultures all over the world
reference a great tournament
of champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
[Applause]
as mortal kombat
these are your champions i'm sonia
that's kano i'm luke
jackson
the fate of earth is in our hands
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail kill them
[Music]
i am zero
get over here
you [ __ ] beauty
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learned
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one you'll lose
that one too
arrakis is a death trap
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
an animal caught in a trap will go off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
[Music]
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
hello duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go go
[Music]
[Music]
from your secret friend underneath
[Music]
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
you're becoming quite a celebrity
[Music]
why's he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
this guy's crazy
you're tired of this too
how am i part of this
you'll see
this is our only chance
we have to take
we need calm the world needs him
to stop what's coming
and this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go
so i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way khan did
the same
so
it's godzilla
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
there's something provoking him that
we're not seeing here the same opinion
the myths are real yeah there was a war
and they're the last ones standing for
greatness
kong bows to no one
so what are you doing out here
[Music]
there is a legend in the jungles of the
amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands he
could awaken
a great evil i believe that the legend
is
real and i'm gonna find it what you want
when i do just imagine the lives that
could be saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked a legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something that
can't be found
but you've never had the key
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
know this about the jungle everything
that you see
wants to kill you and can
careful they could smell fear i am not
afraid
[Music]
oh my gosh who brings a submarine to the
amazon
foyer
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you the gift you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
[Music]
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this can be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
is an overpowering urge to consume blood
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing huh
what's up guy
how about the pickups i hear there's a
problem
i'm the former police commissioner as a
woman
you're a caretaker hey damon
flourishing you do what i tell you to do
and everything will be just fine
i need you tonight using some of your
old skills
five stops five pickups
[Music]
i need to know right now are you in or
out
let's do this
you got three more stops i need to get
my daughter back
away and it is not safe for me out there
i don't see that you have much choice
tommy's not your friend
[Music]
three more stops two more stops
one more stop
get rid of that for me
[Music]
you